one of the key steps to being an
independent thinker is constantly
seeking out opinions that differ from
your own one of those opinions has been
coming from vladimir putin he continues
to talk in multiple settings meetings
and speeches about the fact that we are
headed toward a multi-polar world his
general thesis is that when russia
invaded ukraine and the united states
and the rest of nato decided to levy
historic sanctions against russia it
created a brand new world regime which
people all around the world have to ask
themselves am i willing to trust the us
dollar and continue to put my faith in
the united states to be my friend now
regardless of what you think about putin
or many of his actions which i
personally don't agree with it is
important to understand how somebody
like him is thinking here's a clip of
one of his recent talks where he's
explaining what it would look like as we
head towards that multipolar world
[Music]
whenever you hear a world leader talk
about the end of the liberal world order
or you see someone saying the world is
changing and essentially calling
checkmate it's worth understanding how
they're thinking why they think that is
the case and what that would mean to the
changing landscape here in the united
states i have no clue what the future
holds but what i do know is that the
financial sanctions have caused a lot of
conversation and we've seen country
after country react differently to them
ultimately the united states and its
leaders i believe are acting in good
faith and they continue to try to do
what they think is best
but understanding every single side of
the evaluation end of the argument is
important it's essential to being an
independent thinker whether you agree or
disagree with vladimir putin his talk
track is very different than what most
people in the united states are thinking
whether you agree or disagree that the
united states will hold on to the global
reserve status with the u.s dollar
ultimately we have to be prepared for
any scenario we have to understand what
those worlds could look like and then we
have to do everything we can to work
towards a better future for ourselves
our neighbors and our children